first of all everyone looks amazing
thank you so much
a little bit of botox lots of sleep
love it love to hear it love to hear it
so let's get started so cool we're
actually talking about the podcast for
real this time i know the last time i
saw you guys was wango tango and i got
the idea but now we're going to do a
deep dive so some actors don't like
watching their work so how many episodes
have you guys actually watched at the
show before doing this
i had maybe watched five episodes
and mostly from the first season and
then when i was 13 i said nope not
watching this anymore i felt so insecure
and so yeah so i haven't seen i would
say you know 95 of the the show i've not
seen so this is gonna be my first time i
think i watched most of the first and
second and possibly the third season
before then i got to a point where i was
like okay that's just my job and i don't
need to watch it anymore um but i had
seen at least maybe the first
three seasons with my family but then
not really since then other than
any time the cult episode used to be on
tv like if i was flipping channels and
it'd be like in reruns and the cult
episode was on i would be like watching
this um and so i would then occasionally
when i would see one in reruns i would
stop and watch but other than that i
have not watched it since the 90s ended
i watched them all when they originally
came out but never since so i've seen
them all once and that was it yeah yeah
as a child star or teen star myself i
feel like
watching
going through your awkward phase and
getting older and watching yourself on
tv
can really like throw you off can affect
your self-esteem can it you know it
affect your experience did you guys ever
feel that way at that age looking at
your work like oh i'm awkward or felt
uncomfortable
all the time yeah that's why that's why
i couldn't watch it you know i mean i
had horrible acne you can actually see
it in the show like and it was covered
in makeup every week for like the first
two seasons you were in there you were
on accident i was in the accutane my
skin was dry oh god it was it was like
yeah
happening too is i started doing all
these team magazine stuff and so they
would do these photo shoots where they
would airbrush my photos and so i always
felt like when i met people on the
street if they recognized me that i was
a disappointment because i'm so ugly
compared to like the version that they
had on their team beat picture that was
totally not me so yeah incredible
amounts of insecurity and and feeling
awful about my image and yeah no you
know that's i think that's why i had to
stop watching the show and i think i
still think it was probably the right
choice i think if i'd gotten too you
know uh too obsessed with how i looked
or you know worried about it all the
time yeah so i ran the other direction
which is funny i have exactly the
opposite thing where i'm far more
insecure about watching the show now
than i was about watching it now um i
don't know why but i get anxious every
time i go to press play i don't know
what the episode's gonna show i hate my
acting
um so i had a lot easier time watching
it at 17 like i'm on tv
then i do now watching it as an adult
from actually looking back from like a
craft or acting point of view it's much
more difficult for me now than it was
that's funny yeah yeah
i didn't i had like a i was pretty
confident and self-assured for the
younger part of my life like 12 to 16
and then right around 16 is when i
started getting self-conscious about my
weight and i gained weight and then you
know i when i turned 18 and i moved out
of my parents house and now i wasn't
like eating my mom's home-cooked food
and i was i had like full agency over
how i was living myself it wasn't as
healthy as it was when i was living
under my parents roof and so i then
became really self-conscious and i don't
necessarily know um that we handled that
in the best way on the show um so yeah i
mean it's it is a really there's a
reason why
child and teen stars have a difficult
time staying on the rails it is a lot of
pressure and uh it can be really hard
yeah no absolutely um what episode are
you most excited about and least excited
about uh watching back
the most episode the most excited about
we've gotten that question a lot the
least excited about i'm kind of
interested
in that like in the first piece and the
first season i'm looking forward to
there's an episode where corey and sean
are old men it's like a flash forward
and we did a whole bunch of makeup and i
just remember having so much fun with
that that scene uh and it's become like
one of the most quoted scenes i think it
was first season i'm pretty sure it's
first year anyway so that's one of the
early ones i'm excited about um the
least excited yeah that's a good
question what's the least i mean i think
there's gonna be a lot of cringe
cringy over acting on my part
some really like self-important serious
dramatic angsty moments that i'm just
gonna oh my god i mean the cult episode
is gonna be super interesting because i
i think i i really committed there you
did you did you uh
i think i am most i'm really looking
forward to actually some of our
timepiece episodes we did like a 40s
episode and a 50s episode and i remember
the 50s episode i got to wear like
lucille balls shoes and i had my
character was chewing gum and every time
she'd spit her gum into a trash can it
made like a ping
and like i look i'm looking forward to
kind of revisiting those because those
are salient for me and i know i have
memories of them so i'm looking forward
to that and i'm really not looking
forward to some of the college years
episodes because there's just some i
think that's where some of our story
lines became really weird like
there was an episode where topanga and
sean
make out
for a college tape to recruit students
but you know cory and topanga are
obviously in a relationship but cory is
bad on camera and so it just gets
replaced with he gets replaced with his
best friend and
that's how they're trying to recruit to
get into the college
like a couple like they wanted
but we actually did we did actually kiss
that's so weird i don't sound i remember
that this episode existed but i don't
remember jack
we actually kissed and the weird thing
is that corey has a problem with it he's
like kind of gets jealous and we act
like
what is wrong with you we're acting like
and yet it's his it's so like that is
yeah wow
who came up with that storyline
like i'm not looking forward to those
moments because those are gonna be the
moments where like i have to have a very
honest conversation about this is not
okay
and i also but i i'm i don't i'm not
trying to like ruin anybody's memories
of the show so i'm i have that in the
back of my mind of like there are people
who really love this and yet i want to
call that one and be like this is weird
yeah i'm looking forward to some of the
some of the the bigger shows too like
kind of the set pieces you're talking
about like we did a black and white
episode you know you know that kind of
thing where we had it was like being at
shangri-la and we had the
whole set was built to look kind of like
casablanca like like stuff like that was
really really cool and i think uh
you know at times eric was um they would
do serious story lines with like sean
and corey where you know like chick like
me was the name of an episode not the
best name of an episode ever but where
you dress like a woman but you do it and
you learn what it's like to possibly be
a woman right and it's very it makes
sense there's a point to it whereas to
be funny one time they just said eric
dressing like a woman because he wanted
to get away from the school bully he
didn't learn anything by it it was just
it was just ridiculous so it's like
that's kind of the stuff i'm not looking
forward to that i don't think is going
to age particularly well right um so
we'll see as we as we go on and as an
actor you're 17 you're 18 and it's like
oh it's funny and you just do it and
then you kind of look back and you go
like that wasn't great there also has
been and it's it's good but there has
thankfully been a bit of a shift um in
so many different ways across society
but one of the ways that it really like
especially doing a show you did not
necessarily
talk back to the right like you as the
actor said what was on the page and you
could have a discussion and you could
say like hey i don't think i want to do
this but like it wasn't necessarily
it wasn't super look look like it wasn't
you weren't necessarily the greatest
person nobody liked working with
somebody who always had a complaint
about something that was going on yeah
and now i think if somebody were to
write something that i would found
offensive or that i felt i thought was
misogynistic i would be the first person
to say this is not yeah i'm not going to
do it because i mean we're adults now
that's like looking back and if you want
to go i wish i had stood up there or you
said something i only did it once and
they actually cut the thing out i
remember that but it was that i was
never that you didn't want to make
weights yeah it was like you didn't want
to make waves so yeah it's very it's
going to be interesting to unpack all of
that stuff as we get to these episodes
so yeah
yeah looking back at some of those
moments for me there's like this weird
sense of like missing those days and it
was such a blip in my memory like i
can't recall most of it and then there's
a sense of like
almost morning you're like i wish i
could go back to those days and enjoy
the like be more present do you guys
relate to that at all absolutely yeah
just wish like like i said earlier like
i wish i could just tell myself to
lighten up and enjoy the process you
know like
i was a little bit older than them so i
loved every moment of it i was i was it
like i was invested like i was there and
it was just the coolest thing in the
world for me and so i i think it doesn't
seem like much but when you're 13 and
i'm 17 that's a big difference in age
you know you're 34 and 38 that's not a
big difference in age but you're 13 and
17. that's that's huge so that's one of
those things where
i it wasn't about being president it was
just that all i didn't want to be an
actor i wanted to be on a sitcom that's
all i wanted to do so now that i've had
that happen
i i loved every every second of it i
really yeah yeah i think also
for writer and i there was a sense
that the show was taking us away from
our real life as opposed to feeling that
the show
was our real life interesting i so badly
missed being at my regular school i went
back to my regular school every hiatus
week i went to every football game i
went to every school dance and so the
show while fun and its own little
subsect of my life felt like but what
i'm really supposed to be doing is this
other stuff and what i think the
yearning is that i have for those days
is realizing that
i was exactly where i was supposed to be
and if i had lived more in the moment i
would have all of the things i thought i
was supposed to get from high school and
from that group of people i could have
had
every day with where i was and i think
as a teenager it's just hard for you to
conceptualize what life really is and
and you you've always feel like you're
supposed to be somewhere else yeah yeah
i think that's true we got to talk about
all this stuff on the show we got so
much fun oh there's so much oh my god
okay when fans come up to you guys what
is like a line they say that the most
often they just hit you with something
i mean for me i hear a lot about from
the episode where i cut my hair people
love to say hello bye i am so at the
mall
um
and so that's a line because it's a very
anti-taping line yeah uh i get that one
a lot
i always get the same thing do the
feeney call i get the same thing do the
feedback everyone wants to hear them
everyone say that i get that or i get
wow because for some reason everybody
thinks i'm like 6'3
so when they actually everybody's
shorter than me on the show for some
reason i'm i'm not even 510 but i was
like one of the taller guys in the show
so when people meet me they're like i
thought you were huge it's like no
not at all
so that i get that one too like you're a
lot shorter than i thought like okay
well thank you do you get a quote i
don't i don't get like one specific line
no i mean the quote that people throw
around the most is not specific to me is
the the last line of the show you try to
do good
but yeah no not a specific you know i
get a lot of emotions though people are
very emotional about the show and you
know they're very touched by and
affected by
the uh the drama which is good but
that's your character and that's what i
was gonna say is that writer so he's
like oh i think i'm gonna you know i was
oh so emotional and really leaned into
the drama and he's so hard on himself
because he in his mind it's like it was
like overacting but it so wasn't it was
very real and it resonated for so many
people who watched and i think it's one
of the reasons why our show truthfully i
think the reason our show gets dramatic
accolades is entirely because of writers
because he carried that emotional
element of the show for us
when we come to it i think we will
thankfully be there to balance him out
because i i remember it and remember
being really blown away i agree i agree
100 i think you and i towards the end
were the ying and the yen you had all
that and then it was like now but will
it and by the way no one absolutely no
one is better at that comedic relief
either so between these two tent poles
the rest of us just got to flit about
[Laughter]
and it's funny because and that might
just be the way we looked at the show
differently because i personally think
most of the show
lasted as long as it did because of cory
and japan right i mean that it was like
that's why a lot of people watch the
show was korean they're related
so it's like we all look at like hey
you're the reason we kept working and
everybody was pointing at somebody else
then to themselves because i too i truly
do think that was corey it's just hard
because we don't like each other we're
not supportive of each other at all and
so like having to see each other every
week is hard
what is something fans would be shocked
or surprised to find out i'm 6'3
when cameras weren't rolling maybe
behind the scenes
i think what you've been saying um
pretty often is good which is that
people think of when they think of
behind the scenes they think of us they
picture the sets and they think of us
laughing and joking in the school
classroom set or in the matthews family
living room set and there were those
moments um but when we were on those
stages that you guys can all picture it
was work time and we had directors and
producers and writers for expecting
performances out of us our real time to
get to know each other and all those
moments that where we bonded and
connected were in the walk from the
stage to the school room or on the walk
from the stage to the cafeteria or the
craft service and it's those
places that like
you guys can't even picture but the
school trailer is so instrumental in our
lives because we had to do school three
hours a day three or four hours a day
every day together in a little school
room with two teachers
every subject all different grades and
so that's what we spend a lot of our
time together wow and we also like
learned from what the other one was
learning because we were three feet
apart at different desks with different
teachers kind of independently studying
and then our teachers helping us but
like i can remember writer just right in
the next room talking about philosophy
with david combs while i was working on
math with you know wesley staples and so
like i'm doing math but at the same time
i'm absorbing conversations that writer
is having and i'm like
picking up bits and pieces about what
he's learning about and i i just think
that's the stuff people could never
but why am i doing that
i know you know this is excellent i'm
just realizing i took latin because you
had done latin yeah because you were in
your senior year in high school and you
were doing something the next year i
decided to pick one yeah
and now of course living in los angeles
would have killed to have been able to
speak spanish
in 60 years of latin but it is what it
is
what can you say
how do we feel about oh it's time to
wrap oh my god okay last question how do
we feel about having fame
before social media and the way that we
see it now so great how many a pluses
can we give fame before social media the
only way to do it yeah the best the best
of the best of the fames i mean social
media is
just
still amazing
yeah i social media is a blessing and a
curse it it is mostly i don't think it's
a blessing at all i think it is awful
listen i think there are when you when
you use it to connect with people in the
way that you are that you are
in the when you live up to your highest
evolved self and use social media for
that purpose which is not the majority
of uses social media can be incredible
for the rest of the time it is just a
garbage can the other 99.8 of the time
it's horrifying yeah i try to focus on
the good that's some of the bad i just
don't have it
and he just got me
his mental health is better it is
almost years now it's great
wow yeah
well well all right i know that's time
it was so nice to talk to you guys i was
watching
and loved watching you guys oh my god so
this is like a full circle moment and i
will be listening to the podcast thank
you we can't wait to see you the next
time i'll see you next time and everyone
will look great
we'll keep always
thank you
bye bye guys
you